hey kids as you know I am one of the
producers on your movie good boys and
unfortunately I'm here with bad news you
guys cannot watch the trailer for your
own movie what it's just too messed up
for kids your age there's drugs there's
violence they're swearing and although
we've decided it's okay for you to do
these things in the movie
you can't watch yourselves do them in
the trailer a [__] up oh it is [__]
up you can say that if you can't watch
yourself say that that's [__] up
welcome to Hollywood I found all these
weapons in my parents closet I think
your parents let me wear this for
Halloween
i'm nabi japanese for nunchucks mother
okay he's know it [__]
[Music]
I'm having a party tomorrow Ewan yep can
throw Lucas come they're my best friends
we do everything together just so random
two weeks in the 6th grade I'm already a
social piranha does this look like a
sippy cup no it's a [__] juice box
cuz I'm not a [__] child you do not
want to go to Shawn's party not knowing
how to kiss we can spy on my neighbor
she's a total nymphomaniac hey stranger
things go [__] yourself
what the [__] this is what happens when
you don't respect women I was begging my
mom's my best me but that's gonna kill
me Joe this is how we get the drone back
picture there's llama burger tree you
took my bag oh my god there's Molly in
there okay
who's Molly cuz she's not with oxidases
Christ
the line is crap here's the plan I'm
gonna go to the party with a beer so
everyone knows that I'm cool what do you
have your pants my penis
pull it out I also have a big dick
[Music]
when you see real people kissing I have
an idea
[Music]
well what do you even kissed well not on
their mouths at least
you